happy monday everyone
so there's big news over at cnn that
doesn't involve a producer molesting
children
for once
i guess even perverts take holiday
breaks
yeah it was announced that cnn has
closed its offices to quote
non-essential employees it's either for
covid or so law enforcement could have a
break
meaning the only people at cnn are
people that are necessary to create
their product but that's not the only
news at cnn besides their usual arrests
here's a delightful picture of what
appears to be a mentally deranged
unstable freak celebrating an act of
arson
yeah it's jim acosta standing with a
group of cnn employees who thankfully
aren't sex traffickers
they're all unmasked of course
which is weird you'd think after the
month cnn had they'd all be wearing
masks to hide their embarrassed faces
but what's he holding yes a picture of
the fox christmas tree surrounded by
faces of fox tv personalities that's
kind of creepy no i mean even for acosta
that guy makes dracula seem less dead
inside
let's take a closer look at it shall we
now obviously it's hard to parse what a
nutcase does but what could it mean
anything he could be mocking the fact
that the fox tree was torched in a
disgusting act of arson that would make
the most sense given that cnn has a
penchant for not only making light of
crime but making crime itself
crime is rising
oh my gosh it's so bad and again
defunding police it's like
if you watch a certain state tv and you
listen to conservative media you would
think that you know
entire cities are just you know enrolled
in fights and fires and whatever we went
out had a great dinner in new york city
tonight people actually walked up to us
and said thank you for i watch you every
night gets me every time
it's a classic classic reminder of how
wrong these chuckle bucket bozos are on
everything that matters
and even the remaining anchors still
have whiplash from looking the other way
from people's misery it's a pattern what
doesn't harm them but harms you they
laugh at because laughing at horrible
realities is a way of coping for cnn and
kamala harris it's their version of a
smoke bomb
so now that that network is the face of
crime instead of covering it they now
cover for it the upside at least we know
where all these people are at any given
time
the only reason why i'm glad don lemon's
on the air is to know when it's safe to
go drinking outside
the guy's more handsy than big ben
who knew once the most trusted name in
news is now a sanctuary city for sad
sacks check out this screen grab
how cute is this got to read that lower
third as cnn implodes under the weight
of sex crimes and firings they
desperately try the look over at fox
news ploy as witness here with the
general of gelato brian stelter
he can't even fool democrats anymore but
i get it when you're now the hood
ornament of media deceit and
self-humiliation this is the only ploy
but look at fox
their entire network is but look at fox
and it's working out
for us
like brian himself our ratings are
massive
on any given night this show has four
yeah four times the viewing audience is
don lemon
yeah
take it
why not
now i know that's like saying i'm four
times better looking than the elephant
man
[Laughter]
or four times a better shot than alec
baldwin
but you'd think they'd learn at this
point
i mean it's like their audience got cnn
kovid killing their ratings dead
good evening i'm not a doctor nor do i
play one on tv but on behalf of the
medical establishment we'd like to
congratulate cnn on successfully
vaccinating yourself against high
ratings
i've never seen viewer numbers this low
now will you need a booster eventually
perhaps by giving a show to some
previously unknown even less talented
cuomo variant
only time will tell
but until then
anyone know what this thing does
so
as they become the spokes network for
mayhem they send their remaining
sensible viewers to us
but like me wandering into a cinnabun
store stoned it's too late for them to
turn back
like george custer they led the charge
in so many awful things they spent a
year letting one anchor deceptively
defend his brother as he sexually
harassed and sent thousands of elderly
people to their death his brother killed
more old people than air horns
joking about his brother's big nose with
a giant q-tip should have tipped off
cnn's brass that this wasn't journalism
then after much outside pressure they
fired him pretending they were disgusted
by the behavior all along yeah i guess
that's why they let him do it for a
really really long time they lied about
january 6 and why not they lie about the
other 364 days a year they lied about
border agents whipping haitians they
lied about so many things they claimed
was worse than watergate and worse than
the civil war yeah worse than the civil
war which ended slavery
yet cnn thought it was bad go figure
they must have hated how world war ii
ended too
they claimed defunding the cops didn't
exist when it did they claimed no one
could prove critical race theory existed
and when people easily proved it did
they called you racist they called you a
terrorist but they already used that for
january 6. in the old days media would
defend their peers rights to say
something they disagreed with but now
cnn claims that freedom of the press no
longer applies to anyone outside their
building they also felt the desire to
punish anyone tangentially related to
their perceived enemies or critics
because they're for ideological
ideological separatism punishment
included and that allows them to be
blind to how outlandish stupid and
biased their content is yet it wasn't
enough to target fox news you got to go
after trump voters parents the police
anyone who dare question masked mandates
they became the mouthpiece for enforced
conformity as they mocked real crime
they happily tried to cancel you for a
meme they ignored mobs destroying cities
while trumpeting phony hate crimes
they'd be happy if we were all on terror
watch lists but there is a bright side
if cnn is too busy focusing all their
energies on fox at least maybe the kids
are safe
frankly i'd rather have their hands on a
picture of a tree than inside of instead
of hiding in one with a pair of
binoculars next to a middle school
so that's the silver lining to cnn's
really year
just don't stand next to the anchors on
new year's eve when they start looking
for someone to kiss you don't know where
that mouth has been
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else